what up space fam goes in here from
anime uproar and i'm back at it again to
discuss the latest
and one of the final chapters of the
attack on titan manga the epic final
battle seems to be
over and the results are absolutely
shocking so make sure to stay tuned for
that if you do enjoy seeing these attack
on titan videos and want to keep them
coming then the best thing you could do
is warhammer smash that like button and
share this video with any attack on
titan fans that you know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select
all or you will miss future attack on
time videos and while you wait for the
next insane chapter to drop
feel free to check out our growing
attack on titan playlist where we got
videos about all the titan shifters and
their powers
all the acronyms and their powers the
titans rank for weak is the strongest
and much more
link to that is in the description now
without further ado
let's jump into it spoilers and all so
first i just gotta say
we got so much more information in this
chapter
things are starting to come together and
although we are still two chapters away
from completely wrapping up the story
some of the theories i mentioned in the
previous videos did end up coming true
and for others they seem more likely now
even if they haven't been confirmed but
let's start at the beginning
interestingly enough
we get another huge perspective shift
attack on titan is known for these
remember when we thought humanity only
existed within the walls
and then we found out what was in the
basement and all of a sudden what we
thought was all of humanity was actually
viewed as a monster race
by the rest of humanity who continued to
go about their lives as the aldians
remain
ignorant on their titan infested island
now the manga is showing us the
perspective
from space and the perspective of a much
broader timeline we're taken too long
ago when nothing existed in this world
eventually something appeared and
survived and we're told that we know
this thing as
life interestingly enough we see an
underwater spine-like creature when
we're told this
again giving credence to the theory that
the spine-like creature that amir fritz
encountered has a will of its own
while people have viewed titan powers as
tools to carry out their ends
it looks like this creature was using
them to carry out its own ends too
meaning its own survival and
multiplication you could say that this
creature connects all aldeans and so the
more
aldeans that are created and survive the
happier it will be
however zeke is the ultimate enemy of
this creature because zeke wants to
cease aldian existence
and this would mean the end of this
creature as well presumably but i'm
getting ahead of myself
we first meet with armin and zeke these
are probably the two most intelligent
characters alive in the world of attack
on titan based on iq
and they're having a conversation about
life and their philosophies about it
inside the unknown land
and keep in mind they have been absorbed
at this point into aaron and his titans
in the physical world for now
fiction just doesn't get any better than
this for me
zeke the older one talks about how life
ultimately survived because
it was in its nature to multiply life
took new forms in order to multiply
adapting to every kind of environment
and eventually leading to
us as we are now it sought numbers
sought to spread
and sought abundance and zeke mentions
if we follow this line of thinking then
the purpose of life is to multiply
the king of elder who took emir fritz as
his wife wanted to do that and the
spinelike creature wants to do that too
and it suggested that it was on earth
way before humans arrive
and as mentioned it adapted by attaching
to a mirror and spreading itself through
the ldn people
the subjects of emir specifically are
those aldeans who have part of that
creature inside of them
and can thus turn into titans by the way
this chapter is fittingly called titans
not only because we are learning so much
about them but because so many appear in
this final battle as well
zeke mentions how non-living things like
sand pebbles the water don't seek to
multiply but
life never stops frantically trying to
do so as a result
death is so feared because it runs
counter to the goal of multiplying and
in a sense living on forever
and z concludes that this is the reason
amir fritz as a kid wanted to avoid such
pain
and thus gave birth to an undying body
this was specifically when she attached
to the spine-like creature
she didn't die like most people she
escaped to a world that was free of
death
and this is the unknown land that we've
seen so much about
where the coordinate is and where all
the paths connect armin realizes that
that girl was the founder and that the
place they're in now is the place free
of death but wonders about amir's goal
zeke says he spent a lot of time in this
world trying to figure that out and
despite having insane amounts of power
amir fritz never defied king fritz but
rather obeyed him for 2 000
years she still felt attached to the
real world she left behind and aaron
understood that
saw her as that human when z couldn't
and that's why she went with him armin
is the guy here still
trying to get back to the outside world
he still has a hope and purpose while
zeke seems to have given up
zeke wonders why armin wants to keep
going is it just to keep multiplying
pretty much what this chapter is about
is what is the purpose of life and why
keep going if there's no purpose or if
the purpose is just to multiply and die
later anyways
deep stuff and i love the fact that
attack on titan is tackling such
important philosophical questions
so openly zeke says that what we're
seeing now pretty much referring to the
rumbling and the destruction that aaron
is causing can be called the miserable
sight of life forms
controlled by fear a fear of not
multiplying of death of the end
and there's truth to this aaron is doing
what he's doing because he feared the
rest of the world would eradicate his
people
and his people are the subjects of emir
so it's completely possible that the
spine-like creature was also
influencing him since it wants to keep
the subjects of emir going
too since they're kind of like its hosts
and ensure its survival and expansion
zeke is talking in a very abstract way
while armin is more concerned
with the immediate and concrete he says
his friends are fighting right now
he doesn't want to give up because he
can still save so many people from
terror
armin wants to fight fear the fear that
leads to these kinds of catastrophes
zeke wonders what would be so bad about
losing the fight living means you're
going to die anyways one day so why not
give up
perhaps giving up and dying brings
relief according to zeke
and then he says i quote maybe the end
of your day is being manipulated all in
the name
of multiplication without ever knowing
if it means anything
at all feels like freedom end quote and
so in zeke's view aaron's constant
fighting for survival which he calls
freedom is pretty pointless
perhaps ceasing to exist is the answer
not frantically struggling to survive
even if it all might be pointless armin
though refuses to accept zeke's
conclusion he finds a leaf in the sand
he picks it up and remembers how he had
a race with mikasa and aaron when they
were kids
as he ran armin felt a nice breeze and
he was in a really good mood
he thought at that moment that maybe he
was born for this so the three of them
could race on this gorgeous day
he felt the same when he read on a rainy
day or when he fed
nuts to a squirrel and so on he felt
like these trivial moments
not to mention fleeting moments might
actually be precious
these moments are precious even if they
don't necessarily advance the biological
goal of multiplying your genes
so armin is saying here that
reproduction and survival
isn't the only point of life rather the
point of life is to live it specifically
to live it fully
in the present moment if you lived fully
in the moment and appreciated it it
doesn't matter that you'll die one day
there is value in having experienced it
even if it doesn't last forever where
armin sees the leaf
zeke sees a baseball he remembers how he
used to play catch with tom the previous
beast titan user
and zeke actually agrees with armin
saying that just throwing
and catching and throwing and catching
over and over again with tom was in a
sense meaningless
there wasn't some grand goal behind it
but he still enjoyed it he would have
much rather have kept on playing catch
and i really like this moment most
people would agree that we create our
own meaning or purpose in life but i
like
armin's view that it doesn't have to be
this grand thing
like saving the world or becoming the
best it can just be
enjoying the beauty that life has to
offer and cherishing the connections we
make with each other
while we're here the little moments can
be what it's all about and this truth
resonates all the more when very
outwardly successful people like jim
carrey say stuff like
and i quote i hope everybody can get
rich and famous and will have
everything they ever dreamed of so they
will know that it's not the answer
end quote don't get me wrong there's
nothing wrong with pursuing goals
but don't expect to feel everlasting
happiness
just because you accomplish your
external goals whether you're richer or
poor
once you reach the basic requirements of
life your happiness will depend more on
how much you fully
live life in the present moment and on
the strength of your connections with
friends and family than it will
on your bank account armin is on to this
and even if rome falls and your name
gets lost in the endless sea of time
that doesn't matter because it's all
about being here and now
living your best life and connecting
with the people around you
i should be getting back to the chapter
but wow this is some amazing
philosophical material to work with
we then see the past titan shifters
grisha kruger
tom emira the survey corps marcel and
porco before we jump back to the fight
with aaron's insane titan body and the
colossal titans marching forward
pique has been injured and is saved by
jean it's interesting to see a survey
corps member saving a marlene warrior
that he doesn't really know that well
aaron has really brought everyone
together as they try to stop him and
maybe that was part of his plan
for a long time we've been entertaining
the possibility that aaron was pulling
some kind of lelouch
zero requiem kind of move where he
directs all the hatred on him and so
people can
overcome their differences the thing is
he probably ended way more lives than
necessary if this was his plan but it
clearly has brought the people who
remain together
and he gave them the free will to fight
him so there's that too
reiner is not in good shape and it's
become a meme at this point
reiner has been getting beaten up for
his whole career it feels like he now
has many weapons stuck inside him but
just as things look horrible berto's
colossal titan shows up
and i mentioned the possibility of
bertolt and the others being able to
control their titans in past reviews and
it looks like that is what's happening
here which is interesting because in a
way
none of them are really dead in the
sense that they are gone forever like
amir fritz they seem to reside somewhere
in the unknown land and can come back in
these kinds of special circumstances
of course bertolt helps annie's female
titan while she's in trouble he had a
huge crush on her and probably still
does and armin seems to have taken over
as that crusher after his death but
nonetheless you know bertot is going to
do everything in his power to save the
girl he loves we see porco and marcel
also exercising free will in their titan
forms
attacking the other titans that aaron is
summoning amir of the survey corps and
her dancing titan make an appearance too
this is actually a really cool
occurrence to have in one of the closing
chapters because all of these characters
from the past come back for this one
epic attempt to stop aaron's god-like
titan it's literally
aaron and the founding titan versus
everybody and everybody even includes
characters that have passed on mikasa
takes the opportunity to finally get the
titan-holding armament
after gabby hits it in the eye armin is
saved and the much-hated gabby had
something to do with it there is so much
hate for gabby in the anime watching
community now
i look forward to seeing if at least
some of them will change their opinion
about
her as the anime progresses to the end
clearly she's not as bad as she was
before
nor is brainwashed still it's hard to
forgive a character who killed our
precious potato girl
the cool thing is after the titan tries
to stab armin
and get him back he attacks it everyone
plays a role in saving him even himself
and also connie who cuts the tongue
of the titan so that armin doesn't drop
down with it and then annie who should
definitely end up with armin catches him
in the hands of her female titan armin
is soaked in titan fluids
as they make eye contact that's about as
romantic as attack on titan gets
as annie is about to be attacked we see
krueger's titan grisha's titan and what
we can assume is tom's beast titan which
seems to be a sort of ram
helping out they play a role in saving
annie it was already suggested before
but it's even clearer now that grisha
does not want aaron to carry out his
plan and neither does kruger an
interesting development for former ld
restorationists and possessors of the
attack titan
then even zeke helps levi find him he
waves over to him
you know it's the ultimate team effort
when even levi and zeke are on the same
page
zeke wants levi to cut off his head and
end the suffering and death because
remember
if zeke gets killed then aaron won't
have access to the founding titan power
anymore because he no longer has a royal
blooded titan
levi seemed so confused during this
whole thing he probably wanted to get
some truly satisfying revenge
after all zeke's done to his friends
comrades and even him but zeke takes
away that satisfying fantasy by
willingly presenting himself to be
killed and so of course levi can't take
any joy in killing him but he probably
does respect zeke more now than he did
before
according to arm and zeke is the one who
woke up those who were asleep in the
world of paths
where neither life nor death exists how
awesome is this stuff i love the
complexities that are woven into the
attack on titan world
it's mentioned that every alden is
connected to one another by the path
because the founder emir wants to be
connected thus we can assume that every
subject of emir who died is still alive
in a sense
just hasn't been woken up as grisha and
the others were
zeke has a very interesting conversation
with tom he admits that their dream of
euthanization was never realized and he
doesn't think it was a mistake
but now he says that if it meant getting
to play catch with tom again
then he wouldn't mind being born once
more after all
thus even for zeke one of the biggest
pessimists
the joys of life at least cancel out the
suffering he felt like his life was
worth it because of the joyous moments
he experienced with tom and as a result
he also thanks grisha his biological
father for bringing him into this world
and also for making it so that he would
meet tom
there is a very important lesson here
grisha could have been like tom to zeke
he could have prioritized moments of
connection with his son but instead he
just treated him as a tool in his grand
plan to restore elder
then we jump to armin who tells bertolt
that he took everything from him his
life
power precious memories and he doesn't
mention it but he could probably add
annie into the mix too
armand though still asks for his help
like zeke asks for toms and grishas and
as we see they do help and zeke as he's
about to get killed looks at the
beautiful day
a beauty he could never see when his
mind was always somewhere else focused
on accomplishing his master plan at all
costs
he wishes he realized earlier how
beautiful life can be
if you take the time to notice but he
admits that after all the killing he's
done
that's asking for too much and i know i
always reference code geass because it
is awesome and it's one of my favorite
series just like attack on titan is
but zeke didn't just kill he was also as
loose advised
prepared to be killed and you can at
least respect someone like that more
than someone who kills with no mercy but
then clings to life and does anything
possible to survive levi finishes the
job and you can
see in his face that he's conflicted he
carried out what he had to do
but he's not happy about it and so ends
the rivalry between
zeke and levi and it ends in a much
different way
than we probably expected in the end
their rivalry finished with an
understanding and
in an agreed-upon manner the rumbling
stops and jon finally activates the
explosives around aaron's titan's neck
the spine-like creature tries to
reattach to the head but this time
people are ready
reiner's titan tackles the creature and
although we definitely can't be sure at
this point
there is a very real possibility that
aaron might die it doesn't feel final
enough
so we'll definitely have a better sense
of what's going on in the next chapter
but anything can happen at this point
and it's clear to me that aaron was
prepared to die
as reiner holds the creature the others
prepare to get away on the flying titan
while armin prepares to blow up
all the bones and probably the creature
too with the explosion ability of the
colossal titan
and i like it here that drawn knows how
the armor titan can actually withstand
the colossal tight explosion this is a
point i've brought up in many past
videos
and it makes the armor titan pretty cool
and unique either way though rhino 2 is
prepared to die if that's what it takes
armin thanks the titan shifters of the
past who came back to help them
saying without them they wouldn't have
been able to stop aaron or the rumbling
they hold
armin as he prepares for the explosion
and he says goodbye aaron
as the explosion begins we see mikasa's
tortured face as they fly away
on the very cool looking flying titan
and we should only have two chapters
left by my understanding
it is almost all over and wow this
chapter was extremely packed with
significant
actions philosophies and titan
information this series is keeping up
the amazing quality right up until the
end and it may very well be my favorite
series ever
in two months when we know how it ends
let me know your thoughts on
this chapter and what you expect to see
happening next is aaron gone forever as
armin is implying remember this wouldn't
be the first time aaron appeared to be
dead
but ended up surviving i can already
think of at least two cases
where that happened so definitely don't
count him out yet but yeah the remaining
world
saw aldian save their butts from the
threat that was about to kill them so
hopefully armin will get his wish and
people will be able to move beyond their
fears
and come together in peace perhaps such
a view is too idealistic
perhaps maintaining peace will always be
a struggle but at least they could enjoy
the little moments like playing catch
and running around in the breeze with
friends
while they can and that is it for
today's video i hope
you enjoyed if you did and want to keep
the attack on titan videos coming
then the best thing to do is warhammer
smash that like button
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select
all or you will miss future attack on
time videos and while you wait for the
next
insane chapter to drop feel free to
check out my growing attack on titan
playlist where we got videos about all
the titan shifters and their powers
all the acronyms and their powers the
titans drank from week is the strongest
and much more
link to that is in the description and i
especially want to thank the patron
squad over on patreon and here on
youtube who helped make videos like this
one possible first and foremost i want
to thank the patron of legend the one
acknowledged by lord tuigo himself
and the most donated champion of the
world alpha sigma
and are the one-tier patrons the ones
who stand up all clans in grata the
world acquire respect pate heffa
liam thompson al-jatal dr cortman
johnny boy draws emperor otaku spidey
life tinel baked buddhist and tungsten
tarkis
and are pro hero to your patrons the one
and only gilgamesh steelers angel cruz
anatoly kazatsuki joe stanton very gucci
jessica kayla fond rathu and aura alicia
actor bonnie parks hinokami and water
the red-haired raven joanne garcia jack
watches anime fat boy games deadly saint
matthew cruz
and anthony schreiber thank you all so
much if you enjoy our work you can
support more of it by going over to
patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar if you do so
you'll get your name featured in future
videos alongside these
epic people right here and you'll even
get access to our private patron only
discord where we talk about anime life
and of course
dank memes so check out patreon.com
anime upload link in the description
if you're interested you can also join
the youtube channel by clicking that
blue join button next to the subscribe
button that you've hopefully
already destroyed so you can support
work on that way if you prefer
and whichever way you choose to support
us you can get the same
great benefits thanks again and until
next time
see ya space cowboys
[Music]
don't
you